So my name is Gabe Savo, I work at Victor, a sub user data scientist. And I
actually come from a background that's, that's more towards
natural sense, sciences. I did statistical physics, I have
a PhD in statistical physics. And anything that goes
with that, obviously, I was looking at like a
lot of big, big systems that that kind of.
Emerge as an interaction of, of very small very
small entities composing of these systems. And
and later on I, I did complex network
research. So that means that we have interactions
again. As in this, in this, imagine like
a big gas composed of molecules. But
instead here we have like, the humans interacting
with, with each other through social networks. Through
mobile communication networks. So that was the main
focus of my research all year.